Terrifying pictures out of northern Japan.
An earthquake - triggered tsunami sent a destructive wave across the northeast coast.
These are pictures from the city of Sendai in Miyagi Prefecture.
The wave washed across farmlands, carrying entire buildings with it.
In Kamaishi, the tsunami swallowed up cars, buildings, and boats as it crashed inland.
The magnitude 8.9 offshore earthquake touched off a massive fire in an oil refinery in Ichihara near Tokyo.
In the capital, the quake and several large aftershocks violently shook buildings.
It was so strong that here in Tokyo, we really felt it. I've been in Japan for 9 years.
The strongest earthquake that I've felt.
More aftershocks are expected.
Japan's Prime Minister says the government will do everything possible to minimize damage.
And we ask the people of Japan to continue to be cautious and vigilant.
Officials have issued a tsunami warning for the entire Pacific region including Hawaii and Guam.
The Philippines have ordered coastal evacuations.
Noel Waghorn, the Associated Press.